nah the album is amazing man um
i think you got a top five jay covers
ever from him
and uh stupid he was too but i think i
think uh
he got he got versus it just
just like that
but just being on the [ __ ] and in that
vibe because sometimes we don't always
get to catch our favorites and the vibe
that we appreciate them and and and love
them
i'm saying people who say that about me
you know what i'm saying when i when i
uh did the hit boy or when i did the
plugs i met too they're like yo uh i
mean they want to hear me and i'm saying
that they want to hear me a certain way
a lot of people want to hear bro
like that even though he probably feel
like he got [ __ ] like that i'm saying
they just went that's yeah i mean at
least like a recent remembrance i'm like
this is one of the best and cole went
the [ __ ] in on his album i loved his
album um that was my album of the year
last year shout out to cole but in
general like i feel like
you know when when you're calling you
know you're doing this benny record and
you hear the way you came on it because
i'm sure he heard your [ __ ] too
i mean yeah because he picks up where
your verse ends a bit you know
um
you gotta he's gotta you know it's
competition yeah man it's like
you're gonna play different in the
finals and you're gonna play the at the
rucker you know exactly and i love that
i love to be be able to have the type of
to bring something to the to the
to attract and make somebody want to
you know i'm saying to bring to bring
something crazy or bring something just
as that you know what i'm saying
because you know that's what we need as
artists i know i need that you know i
mean still sharp and still you know i
mean because we've seen people i've seen
people who don't be around the same
level
uh as talent as them and and they take a
you know i mean they should take a hit
because they're not you know they
[ __ ] around like no i'll get back to
sharks around i'm saying so the video
just getting him to do a video is a big
deal man that's huge that means he
respects you that means and also for the
record cole's just doing what cole wants
to do nowadays that's it so if he's
doing something i'm assuming you didn't
pay him right he that [ __ ] no we we
don't know man like it's a mutual
respect it's something that he wanted to
do i don't think i just don't feel like
cole's the kind of guy who's doing
features for money if he does it
exactly that's why he even said for a
second he wasn't [ __ ] with features
because he don't he don't do that [ __ ]
like he he do it for the people that he
want to do it for it it's no he can put
a dollar amount on that [ __ ] rich as
hell that's some real [ __ ] that is some
real [ __ ] um